sometimes we just can't bring ourselves
to finish a TV series we might tune out
of a comedy because we just don't find
it funny or give up on a drama because
we don't care about the characters but
sometimes we have to abandon the show
just because it's too disturbing there's
nothing more disturbing than good
old-fashioned human cannibalism who
knows what we'd succumb to if we had no
other choice
trapped without food like the plane
crash survivors in the movie live but
Hannibal the cannibal yeah he eats
people because he likes it also he's a
psychopath he's had a mild seizure that
doesn't seem to bother you said it was
much NBC's Hannibal aired for three
seasons and was so bloody and disturbing
that one newspaper op-ed led to its
disappearance from one of the network's
Utah affiliates the Salt Lake Tribune
TV critic chronicled the shows various
horrors describing among other gleefully
gory scenes quote the naked body of a
woman and pale Donn antlers bodies
carved up so that their backs are
splayed like grotesque angel wings
characters dining on human body parts
people buried alive covered in compost
and fed sugar water so they grow fungus
all over their bodies so yeah if you had
to give up on this one in order to save
your soul or your stomach
we understand sadly HBO's limited series
sharp objects based on the novel of the
same name by gone girl scribe Gillian
Flynn he isn't likely coming back for a
second season but even if you couldn't
make it through the first because of how
discomforting it was you'd definitely be
totally forgiven
[Applause]
Oh truer friends murdered Amy Adam stars
in the series as Camille Parker a crime
reporter who returns to her hometown try
to solve the murder of two young girls
the premise alone is pretty disturbing
but Camille's self-destructive behavior
adds a whole other layer that might be a
bit triggering for people who have
experienced similar issues the series
features such heavy topics as alcoholism
addiction self-harm and human brutality
Patricia Clarkson co-stars as Camille's
mother whose dysfunctional relationship
with her daughters adds an even more
bone-chilling creep factor that may just
be too much for some viewers thank you
should leave I'm here on a social visit
your presence here is inappropriate we
weren't done talking yes you are
remember all those old-timey monster
movies from when you were a kid well
showtimes penny dreadful takes those
characters you loved growing up and
twists them into a disturbing and bin
jabal gothic horror TV series the night
creatures have been eating a sight it
would have been don't you think sir the
show features a handful of beloved
literary characters like the mysterious
Dorian Gray Count Dracula Victor
Frankenstein and his creature and dr.
Jekyll
but while the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen brought all of these
characters together and made it fun
penny dreadful aims to scare and
disturbed the series visits the
hellscape that was 19th century mental
institutions touches on seances in the
supernatural it features tons and tons
of blood so it's totally understandable
if you'd rather watch Sean Connery romp
around league or even Hugh Jackman's
action take on Van Helsing at least
those won't make you feel like losing
your lunch created by Charlie Booker
Netflix's Black Mirror is much like the
twilight zone or the Outer Limits
telling an assortment of stories in an
anthology format so if one episode of
black mirror freaks you out it's quite
possible that the next will as well
and the next and the next
the most disturbing thing about black
mirror is how close to home it feels
while other shows on this list are said
in supernatural environments are focused
on singular disturbing characters many
of the episodes of black mirror feel
like they could actually happen in the
near future by focusing on technology
and how it shakes the way we live the
series is able to predict some of our
worst nightmares and offers up scenarios
that have terrifying results it's
understandable if the premise of the
show has you avoiding your beloved
gadgets like the plague after tuning in
for so many messed up shows about serial
killers you might think it a good idea
to revisit some good old gothic ghost
stories and if you're looking for a fun
romp and not to be scared out of your
wits don't turn to Netflix's the
haunting of Hill House the show offers
up both jump scares and imposing creepy
feeling of impending dread based on the
1959 novel of the same name by horror
fiction master Shirley Jackson the
series follows a set of siblings whose
lives are forever damaged by their time
spent living at the notorious Hill House
the story jumps back and forth between
multiple time periods and it's nonlinear
nature contributes to the universe it
creates especially in that episode yeah
you know which one we're talking about
it's time to wake up speed
but if you can make it through the
disturbing glimpses of ghosts murders
hauntings in general horror then you're
in for a surprisingly touching tale of
one families struggle to escape their
dark past in hope of a stable future
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]